two one nine two david p is our
voicemail number you can call any time
of day
here is a caller who has another idea
about what maybe donald trump meant when
he talked about fire fury and force like
the world has never seen before take a
listen to this i like this hey David how
you doing love the show you really know
your stuff thank you I had a quick
question
so Trump just recently threatened fire
in fury unlike the world has ever known
against North Korea and I think people
automatically assume that we're talking
like something nucular
yeah did he have access and be bragging
about some kind of technology and this
is just a shot in the dark that could be
alien or okay that's kind of crazy but
is there some technology the world has
never seen worse than nuclear just a
quick question I was wondering yeah
that's awesome that all right thanks but
you know I would not put anything past
Donald Trump in terms of what he thinks
do I believe we have some kind of alien
technology that would be far more
destructive than nuclear weapons no do I
think it's possible Donald Trump thinks
we have that that I am actually open to
Trump might genuinely think we have
something like that usually when people
say out of this world or the likes of
which the world has never seen before
they're talking about you know it's just
like an expression but maybe Donald
Trump is using it quite literally so
with the color suggesting I guess so and
I guess I hope that we never find out
that's my final thought and I hope we
never find out we've got a great bonus
show for you today every day we have the
regular show which is free to everybody
and then we've got the bonus show which
is available to our paid members you can
get access instantly to the bonus show
if you sign up at david pakman.com slash
membership today on the bonus show we
will be talking about a transgender day
camp that will include four-year-olds
who are struggling with their gender
identity much to the controversy that
has started as a result of that decision
video has captured a jogger shoving a
woman
to the path of a bus on a London Bridge
police are now seeking your help really
anybody's helped to identify the man in
question and we will talk about the
upcoming great American Eclipse which we
will hear from Pat about in terms of his
plans for the Eclipse on the Friday
bonus show will be great American
eclipse of August 20 21st make animals
act strangely science says yes and we
will discuss that on today's bonus show
sign up at david pakman.com slash
membership coupon code
I voted 17 if you don't want to deal
with the membership stuff throw us a few
dollars to cover our production costs in
the wake of the YouTube ad boycott and
lawsuit threat which I talked about
yesterday at patreon.com forward slash
David Pakman show